good morning Hank it's Friday April 2nd
four days before the new book I wrote
with David Levithan Will Grayson Will
Grayson comes out mm-hmm so shiny
obviously we're hoping that a lot of
human beings will enjoy this book but we
also wanted to target the secondary
audience of cats they like shiny by the
way there is a link at which you can
pre-order Will Grayson Will Grayson in
the doobly-doo I spent three years
trying to learn the location of the
doobly-doo only to have YouTube's move
it to my pants
the book is about two guys both of whom
are named Will Grayson who are different
people and David writes from the
perspective of one will Grayson and I
write from the perspective of the other
and in the middle of the book they meet
at a porn store but there's nothing
pervy about it by the way this is
definitely a book for high school
students and up it's not a book for
middle school students or elementary
school students or preschool students or
Henry I wrote the odd-numbered chapters
and David wrote the even-numbered
chapters David and I have been working
on this book for more than five years
since before Looking for Alaska was
published and so it's crazy exciting and
nervous making to have it finally coming
out and to see you know the beautiful
shiny shiny cover and so anyway heck in
keeping with tradition I thought I'd
read to you from the beginning of the
book story time when I was little my dad
used to tell me will you can pick your
friends and you can pick your nose but
you can't pick your friends nose this
seemed like a reasonably astute
observation to me when I was eight but
it turns out to be incorrect on a few
levels to begin with you cannot possibly
pick your friends or else I never would
have ended up with tiny Cooper tiny
Cooper is not the world's gayest person
and he is not the world's largest person
but I believe he may be the world's
largest person who is really really gay
and also the world's gayest person who
is really really large tiny has been my
best friend since fifth grade and but so
a few weeks after we get back from
Christmas break or junior year I'm
sitting in my assigned seat in pre count
when tiny waltzes in wearing his Jersey
tucked into his chinos even though
football season is long over everyday
tiny miraculously manages to wedge
himself into the chair desk beside mine
in precalc and every day I'm amazed that
he can do it so tiny squeezes into his
chair I am duly amazed and then he turns
to me and he whispers really loudly
because secretly he wants other people
to hear I'm in love I roll my eyes
because tiny falls in love every hour on
the hour with some poor new boy they all
look the same
skinny and sweaty and
and the last an abomination because all
February tans in Chicago are fake and
boys who fake tan I don't care whether
they're gay are ridiculous
you're so cynical tiny says waving his
hand at me I'm not cynical tiny I answer
I'm practical you're a robot
he says tiny thinks that I am incapable
of what humans call emotion because I
have not cried since my seventh birthday
when I saw the movie all dogs go to
heaven
I suppose I should have known from the
title that it wouldn't end merrily but
in my defense I just turned seven anyway
I haven't cried since then I don't
really understand the point of crying
also I feel like crying is almost like a
sign from deaths of relatives or
whatever totally avoidable if you follow
two very simple rules one don't care too
much - shut up
everything unfortunate that has ever
happened to me has stemmed from failure
to follow one of the rules so I think
that's a little from the beginning of
Will Grayson Will Grayson nerdfighters I
hope you guys like the book I hope to
see a lot of you on tour oh and the
winners of the advanced readers copies
of will Grayson Will Grayson your
YouTube user names are in the doobly-doo
I hate having to point at my own pants
in order to tell people that there is
information contained outside the video
screen by the way Hank nerdfighters when
was the last time you cried for me it
was not when I was seven it was when I
was yesterday
peg congratulations on writing the best
song ever about chatroulette I will see
you on Monday